. We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. Here is a Bernie voter who so far
is pleased with Joe Biden.
Take a listen to David O, the big Bernie supporter.
And I wasn't naive enough to think that voting
for somebody else would benefit the Democrats
or my beliefs as a progressive, whatever Biden
and whatever Biden right now.
And like you said in the first six or seven
days, he's actually already impressed me.
I understand it's only executive orders and
others in the Senate or the House yet, but
I actually feel more optimistic than I originally
did.
And I'm really excited about it.
And thanks, David.
And by the way, this is Sarah from Wisconsin
and his wife, Jane.
Thank you.
You're still too busy.
I like the yellow one right near Star Trek
a little bit.
I think they appreciate everything.
Was that my sweater is filthy, busy.
I've never heard that.
I don't know what the kids these days are
talking about, but I've never heard that before.
I think that that's very interesting to hear.
And I've heard from a bunch of Bernie supporters
who are saying so far, I mean, for the first
week of Joe Biden, he's really actually done
quite a few things, including things like
freezing a Saudi arms deal that I think very
few people expected him to do, certainly within
the first week.
So we will continue tracking and holding Joe
Biden accountable, but much to be pleased
about in the first seven or eight days.
We have much to talk about on today's bonus
show, including this is crazy.
China is deploying an anal swab for covid
testing.
Why?
Why is this necessary?
We will talk about the medical elements involved
there.
Also, the pences, Mike and Karen are apparently
homeless and couch surfing right now.
What is going on?
With that and more on the game, stop short
squeeze on today's bonus show.
Sign up at join Pakman Dotcom.
I'll see you there.